[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to this stream
sponsored by samsung i'm cam robinson
and i'm joined
once again by jan lopez black girl
gamers hello again
i'm good i'm good i'm trying to avoid
crashing good that is always a good way
to be
now once again we are putting this huge
tv in front of me
the samsung q800t through its paces
when we pair it with the xbox series x
because basically what we're trying to
do is find
uh an ideal tv that kind of matches and
pairs with
the new generation of consoles jen do i
call it the next generation even though
it's currently
there needs to be a word between between
next-gen
it's probably just new anyway we are
playing star wars squadrons as you can
see
and what's your first impressions of of
playing this game on like a 65-inch tv
yeah i was saying i think this oh see it
was crushing
i was saying that this is um a perfect
game for
a tv this size because it really feels
like you're in the in the cockpit
for the for the ship yeah and you can
see all the controls
wow even also see everywhere
i love how the subtitles were a scream
again come on i'm out i'm out oh well
and there you go and you can really see
your own death really well
on the 65-inch tv that was not planned
so we're actually just in the training
mode at the moment a good a good thing
apparently
it needs a little bit of practice i
think but what we're going to do is um
there's a multitude of modes that we can
show off
in squadrons if you've not played it
it's really really good fun
and um there's a great like story which
we dabbled in earlier which we will jump
into at some point there's some
multiplayer which maybe might give a go
um but yeah i think it's a great it's a
great game
on a huge tv like this because as you
were kind of just saying there
it really helps to have your field like
as much of your field of view
in this cockpit and also because we're
like we're pretty professional aren't we
jan we've uh
we've disabled the worst we've disabled
the like
artificial hud and weird watch out i got
it i got it oh
is it because you're playing in the um
with the inverted controls that i set no
no or have you said it back no i've said
it back okay it's just uh that that's
just thanks cam that's just my stuff all
right i was trying to give you
mine um okay so shall we jump into now
you know
practice let's go takes back to the main
menu and let's show this game off
um because the the beginning is pretty
impressive
um what i like about it as well is that
this game
doesn't just put you you know like in
the playing as the empire
empire or playing as a rebellion it you
jump between the two so you get to kind
of play
both parts of a unique story which is a
lot of fun because usually you know
you'd think you would just be playing as
the rebellion yeah yeah definitely i am
a bit of a rebel myself so i think we're
going to go for a rebel
meanwhile fairless the pilots enforce
the world of the galactic empire so is
this
i wonder if this is going to reload our
save or if we're jumping back i
absolutely think i went back
to no that's good i think we want to
start from the beginning okay
um because then everyone watching well
yeah we are so
yeah you beg so this is the thing that
confused me you begin by
oh you're customizing your two pilots
right okay so i assumed
incorrectly same i was choosing my pilot
but actually it lets you customize
your pilots and it says it right there
on the screen that's a good tip
read the screen um so yeah you can you
can customize both so let's uh
let's customize our pilots all right so
how about you make one i'll make the
other okay so i will do bly
okay libasco yeah it's good oh wait
didn't i just oopsie that's my bird
um customize a
so let's see you can see there's a
yeah you've got range of heads yeah
oh even have some non-human non-human
heads
that's dope can we do those skeletons
okay human pilot ten
if it's a fight they won't it's a
uh i think we'll keep it there if your
name's blair blasco why would you change
your name i think it's an awesome name
right yeah
okay i think i think we're good yeah
which one you're going for
um the zeltron okay
oh no no you went back yeah i think no i
think that's what i wanted because i
didn't think you could get those
oh okay cool all right you're okay all
right so i'll make our
rebel pilot um
so you have a number of choices here as
well
uh okay
yeah quite quite a good range i think
i'll go this is who i made earlier i
like i like this look so go for this
character human character number 10 of
course yes okay
uh yeah okay
oh actually that's kind of like a
starbucks
i'll take that and psy okay so i think
it
invents names for you each time
yeah yeah that's cool because that's
different from last time um
okay cool okay and then when you accept
so this is where we chose this is this
is what the instruments are instruments
only and by pros i mean people here are
getting ready to die a lot
um okay except we should play in pilot
yes yes yeah i don't think we're very i
don't think we should
no not overly confident accept and start
game are you ready to play single player
story
yes okay over to you all right please
speed um
how would you describe your um your star
wars
band fandom where are you at um i think
i'm
amateur to intermediate like between the
two
i did grow up liking star wars a lot as
a kid but i kind of fell off as an adult
and then john boyega was in the movie
and i was like well i got to watch it
now
so i watched that and um but i'm not
someone who
knows everything so i'm not someone who
knows like you know uh darth vader's
second
wife's maiden name i don't know those
things lewis obviously yes
um right yeah okay what about you um
i'm a recent addition to well relatively
recent edition star wars
yeah i never watched it when i was a kid
um blame my parents
they uh we watched like star trek and
uh lots of other fantasy stuff but not
really much
sci-fi fantasy so i remember i watched
star wars for the first time
after i started working at gamespot to
the point that my
current boss at the time who may even be
watching this right now
told me after i'd been the job for six
months it came out that was like oh yeah
i've never seen any star wars
he said to me i would not have hired you
for that oh wow
yeah i know but he missed that but not
but he then made me watch them over the
next
month which actually was great because
watching them afresh
yes yeah obviously i had knowledge of
them because they're it's everywhere you
can't not absorb star wars magic is
commonplace
yeah you used to absorb it through
osmosis as you go around your life but
um it was great watching
the original um films as an adult and
actually really enjoying them um
but it did mean when the newer batch
came around more recently
you know the similarities were really
obvious it's like the story was the same
oh my gosh so that was part of my gripe
when i worked in a cinema i was like
this is literally
the same thread but i've always been a
fan of star wars games though because i
think
undeniably the world is just like
because of being so
perfect it's so cool there's so much
detail and like the politics side of
things
and anyway i realized we're like
narrowing over the story so
just so you know we are neither of these
people because this confused us
we're like which guy which person are we
but um i think these are
going to be our squad mates i've prepped
our usual sigma 9 loadout
no only standard ties today i'm okay
flying old-school set now one of the
things um this might be
really like about a bit oh yeah one of
the things i wanted to mention about the
fact that this tv is i mentioned about
65 inches there's
also 33 million pixels across this thing
just so it's just too many almost two
minutes probably just like the
amount of stars in space maybe even more
i mean let's say yes
let's say similar why not maybe that
magnitude
right ah is this this is your character
one of those characters it's bly blasco
that's such a good other speak he
doesn't need to
he's just he says everything he says
with his lasers right
okay and we've also got generic generic
stormtroopers
i think they're not going to survive
okay here's our tie fighter no although
we've not got to that point yeah what i
really like in this game when i was like
jumping around into the menus earlier is
you can um
customize your your various spaceships
that you'll
use throughout the game yes you can like
i'm not entirely sure to the level
exactly but you can suit them up
basically
make them better but this is where
you'll spend most of your time in this
game this kind of view which
i really like put up your cockpit
systems
acknowledged okay go on aida boot
i love that i yeah these little touches
i'm always a fan of first person games
when you're
when you're like oh is that like my arm
i do think this would be
could be quite cool in br but when
you've got this like
huge uh huge field of view field anyway
yeah it really works
okay target the ship uh i think i did
there we go captain james
all right forward sensor online and
tracking yeah because we've turned off
the huds the additional hud stuff
yeah everything we need to use is
displayed
you know on the on the ship's uh i guess
the ship's sensors directly
which is kind of cool okay okay here we
go
and we're going we're in space have a
plan
wow the rest of the fleet is back
there so we see i'm not enough yeah what
the
losing control losing control one of the
things when we were playing this earlier
we learned
is that you can oh my god you can black
out
if you do pull too many g's um but also
um the key to the dog fighting is not
to be traveling at full speed yeah fully
enough yeah
because your turns are like big sweeping
turns and you can just never catch
anything
but a half speed is the sweet spot
there's no time to get careless please
jay please
there we go there you go
i'm going to give camera back in this
drink
you did say you're a bit of a rebel so
yeah yeah is it
close to the ship don't be an icarus
though
it was just so much on screen i know i
love it
it's just like actually in the ship yeah
there you go they're all to have speed
for fast returns there's your tip
there you go uh can we just there we go
i just had to stop moving for a minute
to set myself right those engines aren't
hot enough to vaporize
oh yeah don't don't get vaporized that's
the other tip they give you
in their tie fire at school they weren't
driving knowing me and i'd drive right
into it
rotisserie chicken
the good thing is all this stuff is
actually really good training for the
mission you're about to do
yeah like flying really close to
spaceships and things like that
is it is part of the story
is ready okay it's time to jump
into hyperspace you know what i keep
doing i keep thinking that's
turn that's why and i keep using it to
turn
which one the left stick oh yeah yeah
yeah keep using it to turn
instead of actually using the right
stick too because see ah right yeah yeah
okay so one of them
the left stick is your throttle and your
um your roll your roll
yeah not your direction and then the
right stick is is your
direction right okay yeah it does take
like getting used to so we have a
dilemma here right because what's that
i don't play inverted and you do i do
like but
the thing is i always thought that
wherever you stand on the
inversion versus non-inversion in fact i
was reading a story in the paper today
apparently there's a study in the uk
right now which is delving into why
people
do like what are the origins of why some
people play in virginia some don't
anyway both are allowed here but i
always figured that the reason i played
inverted is because one of the first
games i ever played
was a flight simulator you know because
when you play flight zone with a
joystick you know you push forward to go
down
pull up to go up and i feel like that's
like cemented in my brain
see i want to fight whoever invented
that because that's the complete
opposite
of me now i know i'm aware i'm aware
it's weird like it seems weird but for
me
it makes logical sense to me because
like i always think of that
the stick is like a neck you know what i
mean so what happens if you
what happens if you push your neck
forward jan you look down
okay so i feel you look up i envisioned
you
trying to strangle yourself no no no not
really
if you push it forward no no no no i
mean my own neck yeah
not someone else's all right so um
so you've arrived at a space station and
you're here to bully
some uh some nice people so i'm trying
to find our captain
oh jay please stop doing that follow
captain
james towards is that captain co-star
haven uh no that's lieutenant carol
it's good when you scan them it tells
you in the middle of your ass
i don't know where i'm going please help
lieutenant
now one of one of the reasons we chose
squadrons
um particularly to kind of put the the
q800t through its test
is because this is a game where we're in
space obviously
and what what do you get in space you
get a lot of dark shadowy tones
you got lots of deep blacks you got lots
of grays and often you're looking for
kind of like gray spaceships amongst the
kind of
lack of space so you really need to be
able to pick out
in those different tones and that's one
of the things that tv is really really
great at
um because it's it's well for one it's
got really high dynamic
range capabilities so something called
qhdr2000
um the reason why it's got 2000 is
because we're getting quite technical
here but when it comes to measuring the
brightness of a tv
you measure in in something called mits
apparently and this has 2 000 of them
that's that's his rating 2 000
yeah and what that means in turn but why
that matters
in terms of modern gaming because all
our consoles all these new consoles can
do hdr
why that matters is because in order to
get really good get make the most of hdr
you need a huge
like a chunk of room between your
highlights and your shadows
and that's what this tv gives us you can
see it you have no excuse for not
spotting
those enemies in the shadows okay i hope
so
i think we can learn how to scan now so
yeah okay
okay but um it just looks beautiful it
looks like
that i think gaseous cloud at the back
is just beautiful
okay so we need to so what we're doing
we're scanning cargo ships right for uh
there you go is that one
okay okay so those guys
they're not they're not harboring the
refugees that's what we're looking for
isn't it
so not much action yet but this is kind
of the training bit teaching you to fly
now obviously um everyone watching right
now our stream is is
running at 1080p but um this tv
this tv is capable of 8k which is one of
the exciting things about it because
obviously currently all these new car oh
my goodness all these new consoles
jeez sorry all right yeah all the new
consoles the ps5 the xbox series x they
are capable
of 8k but they're not they're not
activated for that right now
the great thing with this tv is when
they eventually get there yeah you know
you you will have this tv is ready for
it set up for life but what is also cool
is right now
and we're we've we're seeing this kind
of thing right now is
this tv has upscaling in it so if you're
playing at 1080p
it upscales to 4k and if you're playing
at 4k
it upscales the image to 8k and the way
it does that is like looks at every
frame so
look at this picture we're looking at
right now as you fly towards the space
station looks at every frame
and it works out what pixels are missing
it fills in edges
built in textures so if you go really
close to the screen you can see that
it's an incredibly high resolution image
thanks to the upscaling
all right scan this guy i'm trying i'm
trying scan with the scanners
i like your scat the scanning technique
is similar to your dirt
braking technique
okay from a simple inspection
all right she's so angry isn't she
uh that's the one
i almost have it there we go there we go
there we go hello warning side
warning blast yep
wow you showed it
i showed you i think it needs a bit more
blasting where is it
uh up up up up slow down slow down slow
down
there it is there it is down down down
down down right beneath you
yeah there he is okay i just literally
can't hold it still i think i need the
sensitivity
a little blast cheeky blast
[Laughter]
it's parked underneath it cheeky
amazing oh quick it needs more oh
you failed you failed to destroy us how
dare i
how did you let it slip through your
fingers um i didn't
really yeah need to be more aggressive
with your blasting more aggressive
i thought the aggression was was your
thing in these games
racing games running out of me i've done
about space ones you know i feel like if
you'd be too aggressive you fly out into
space and you'll
come back so you have to be that guy
invested yeah
time to invert team inversion here we go
okay bring your weapon systems online so
it's this one oh okay
okay you all right all right well done
cam just just put me to shame
make it look like a very simple task i
think you just needed to blab
blast it more oh
what i realized these fancy spaceships
don't have a reverse
yeah they don't have any frosting at the
front of their ship
the entire fighter cannot go backwards
oh cycle through target
okay uh james where are you james
captain james he's he's he's friendly
right i don't shoot him
yes okay what was the producer
um
captain james is so chill he's just
relaxed
yeah he doesn't mind amazing
oh okay it's ready to get interesting
here well to be fair you didn't just
pull up and then start shooting people
that's true
oh yeah so explain what's this the power
of stuff all about
so this divert power basically you can
split your ship's power between your
lasers
your engine and in the um
in the rebel ships also your shield i
don't think you have shields on tie
fighters
i think you wouldn't like it
automatically and enabled
okay cool so if you wanted to go faster
you would switch it to your engine so
you could move faster
you want to be more powerful you switch
it to your laser it's like a resource
that you can
use as you want which i really really
like because i feel like you're really
interacting with the ship that way
yeah yeah like it really gives you more
control as well oh
come on come on
uh yeah oh there's loads of them oh he's
right here
ramming speed okay
the defense capability is dropping
that's wonderful
i think there's one set right next he's
right next to me isn't it yeah he's
where is he where is he i honestly don't
know where this guy is
i'm running i'm running away i'm running
away press a to seriously catch me if i
run
there you go you've just targeted one oh
there's one i'm gonna get this one so i
can see
my friends can get other ones yeah
that's right
there we go there we go it's a train he
kind of yeah i think it looks like a
supply train this is cool
okay little bit more left okay that's
right we're pairing up repairing up
there was this guy
how how dare you
i really hope it used to be a race yeah
i was gonna say you're out of range
it's funny that lasers have range you
know they shouldn't really shouldn't
really technically you know
no definitely not in space really they
should just go indefinitely you don't
you yeah yeah i don't think i'm doing
this quite how you're meant to do it
pull up pull up cameron there we go
never recovered from this okay
paramedics oh we bounced my back okay
so you can balance it yeah so i can be
like actually i can be like lasers
or i can be like engine engine party and
then you can or i can do half and half
yeah right gotcha it's pretty cool
all right where's he follow lieutenant
carol oh she's the grumpy one isn't she
yeah she is she's
for the empire is that her no is that
her one must
no generic tie fighter carol where are
you
nope well is that her
no no i'm just gonna go towards where i
think she is
she seems to be oh is that her no your
helix three
are you going the right way we'll find
her she's almost certainly
let me go look on your map no oh no
that's your target
would want to ignore me yeah no i think
you're right i keep thinking she's here
as well
maybe we just go this way we'll find her
oh okay
oh i think i remember i think she's the
other side of this giant part of the
station
yeah yeah you found it i think so
you're doing what i do what's that
rule to turn it's a legitimate
reactivity here we go
oh yeah this is right oh yeah yeah yeah
you might wanna oh oh enemies
x-wings all right now it's now it's got
serious
i'll just look at this wall for a minute
and then
imagine if you did that in a row in a
real fight
what are you doing just looking at the
wall you know are you doing tie fighters
just relax in just a minute all right
all right here we go
uh okay that's that's a friend that's an
a where's the x-wing
there there okay here we go so the x-men
shoot red
right correct and they have shields
though
yeah yeah so lead my target i know how
to fire lasers game
oh they don't he says he says badly
okay okay here we go sorry sorry space
station oh my god come on cameron
you're better than this i'll never be a
space pilot at this rate there we go
there we go okay
i think that was my problem it's my
lasers
it wasn't me because my lasers all along
poor
workmen always build up flames just
lasers yeah exactly
uh okay is this one uh yes yes
he just gave you the slip okay okay here
we go no more mr nice firefighter
nice nice yes see the key is staying
exactly still
and making yourself a target you know
shooting's way easier oh you just missed
one oh i just missed a bunch
okay okay here we go roll up roll
roll up confined uh dog fight this one
yeah it really is
i think it's where it makes it harder
but i guess it keeps stinking
speed lower which maybe makes it
slightly easier for the first mission
yeah yeah actually you're not doing too
bad you're getting them all yeah
so what do you think of the game
visually jan um yeah no i think it's
beautiful
i'm always a sucker for space games for
games like um
any to be honest any star wars games
even the republic one
and um no man's sky and
um what else there is a game on pc that
this reminds me of a little bit is it
elite
oh elite yeah dangerous yeah elite
danger is this like total sim
though yeah yeah very much really cool
have you played that no i haven't i've
kind of watched a couple of streams it
kind of is a bit difficult for me to get
into
it's a little intimidating yeah um yeah
i've actually
i've only played like a tiny tiny bit
never properly yeah
but yeah i've always been like oh i bet
that'd be a really fun game to really
get into
yeah boys when you get into it it's
really good so um
oh someone shot me yes i did how dare
they
i did it sorry i interrupted you no no
no i was just good at the repair
mechanic it always
kind of cracks me up because it looks
like your ship's about to blow up but
it's actually generating
lines yeah um so yeah
it always reminds me i love space games
because i just feel like
you really get to explore pubs obviously
space that you don't get to do normally
i think it's so cool that said though we
are going to have galactic flight soon
they said
right with um oh yeah by the super rage
yeah
there we go and you did that quite
quickly
yeah okay take us home take it home
oh the refugee convoy must be hiding in
there
that's how we're looking for recognition
i know this one's really struggling
i'm struggling to be on side with our
actions here i'll be honest
oh you know what oh you're sorry yeah
you need to you need to
i wasn't i mean why can i not control
this yeah yeah
actually while we're here if you go to
you like menus for a second or something
uh if you go if you go to the options
and go to
video it's worth pointing out that
um this i think this is just on the xbox
series x if you go to the graphics mode
you can choose whether or not you want
to favor a resolution
or um which as it says here maintaining
uh
where possible 60 frames per second or
you can actually put a favorite
favorite performance which will give you
120 frames
now that actually ties in really well
with the 800t because
this tv can do 4k and 120 frames
so yeah however you want to play this
however you want to play this game
the tv will match it which is really
cool we should say that right now in the
studio because we are of course
streaming this to you guys um because of
the kind of restrictions of streaming
hardware
the feed has to go out the xbox into our
streaming hardware
and then back to the tv so as a and
because there is no piece of hardware in
the world that can handle 4k 120
how crazy is that there just isn't the
device it means
oh oh oh yeah it means that we're
restricted
to in the studio right now looking at
um yeah like 4k 60 or in this case
yeah 4k 60 yes right
captain james oh what's happened he's
betraying us
he shot me classic lyndon james
that i don't care who ordered it i
didn't sign up to her innocent refugees
that's right i kind of kind of wear them
yeah there we go
can we can we also rebel
that's how you that's how you do space
flight
love the idea everyone on the eye on the
international space station's just like
it's broken
okay here we go
press ah left to die okay energy to
engine
okay we need that speed boost i guess oh
oh god
oh no i don't i don't need to be boosted
but i don't need this okay so you boast
nice ricochet tactical ricochet
uh oh yeah fire in space
i'm not sure that works um
so that wall came out of nowhere no no
sorry you keep going you can go
i'm not sure we'll live when we played
this bit earlier how many times did i
crash
about eight or something two because it
takes a while to get used to the uh
to the controls like the movement of
this yeah right
it's that it's that bit comes out of
nowhere yeah
it's all going off
you got it you got it you got it pull up
you don't got it you don't got it i
don't cut it
prepare the hole repair the hole
maybe you're like i'll just repair the
hole crap are you going
straight into the wall all right third
time's the charm i've got this yeah i've
got this i'm sure you do i'm sure you do
it's james's fault well done james you
messed up my
my flow yeah yeah you know what
we're really going to get used to this
options menu it's all right
unfortunately it's quite an easy change
there you go that's pretty quick on as
far as yeah it should be fair
yeah i hate when they bury the inversion
like deep in the control center and the
advanced controller yeah yeah
okay yeah i know i know how to divert
power game you have to do it to move
forward
yeah i didn't realize that okay i'm not
even gonna bother but shooting i'm just
going to try
it came out of nowhere you all saw it
you all saw it
that was not my fault
i thought it was just me okay no it's
not just you all right
but yeah let's pretend i did that
deliberately to make you feel better
sure that's that's what happened
that's what happened okay i'm gonna
actually slow down
yeah i think that's what i think
diverting the power to the engines is
that it's a terrible idea yeah
right what are you doing in such a
restricted place okay here we go
see i don't want to spend this entire
stream inside this
strange corridor of doom okay okay yeah
yeah okay come on you've got it come on
come on we got
i'm pulling up i got it yep oh i don't
need to i haven't crashed i don't need
to repair the hole
i think it's the fire yeah probably
there we go
okay all right
way ahead of me let's let's shoot james
shoot james i could you james
i we had
breakfast together probably how dare you
oh
it's all right it's all right it's all
right this may be all right it's
probably
better oh i'm so dramatic i'm literally
flinching
that would have been not the best with
stream okay we made it
but james jason escaped i think
what ships are those i don't know
actually
i'm afraid my uh what does that
acknowledge
oh well that's star destroyer that was
quick
so the the reinforcements have arrived
for the empire
[Music]
this is the epiphanies
they're so sleek yeah they are cool
echo squadron come on make the wings do
their thing where they become x's uh
what's her name sai
oh yeah yeah it was cyan hey i almost
forgot yourself
sai there is
this is more like it this is my favorite
yeah
unintelligible cool cool i like it
that car
he speaks unintelligible he sounds like
he's in trouble
oh it's admiral
have you considered admiral this may be
a trap it's a trap
i love that some people have made like
beats around that
sample is so awesome prepare for
okay so i think this is where it teaches
us how to how to fly the uh the experts
for a quiet patrol
i find the expert way easier to control
to be honest i don't know why
yeah i agreed i think and also it's got
boost mode as well it does
oh i don't think i have that yet you can
see
throttle oh yeah throws up at 64. it
wants me to do half speed there you go
this is like premium for maneuverability
well
okay hey guys it's the glitch and [ __ ]
he really knows what he's doing don't
watch hair
divert part of the engine because that
one just crashed oh yeah it happened
earlier
because they do occasionally collide
with each other some very trained
units come on guys can't believe i'm not
the weakest pilot here
oh laser the right part of the lasers
okay candy
nice oh yeah look at that
it looks better when we're shooting i
love the squelchiness of these lasers
it's a really nice spelling sound okay
what i meant to be doing
uh run systems check run that's what it
was
uh follow shield power oh cool so that's
an additional thing is yeah we can
if we're in a big heavy if we're trying
to escape maybe you can direct
yourself that's fun that means you move
slower
yeah i guess so and your lasers are
worse
and then down to balance power i've
already done a game complete yeah i
really like that concept
mechanic i think it's really good i
can't remember if you've seen that in a
game before
no no and i feel like it's something
that's always said in the in the movies
like
yes you know so you hear it you know
divert power to the lasers
star trek as well yeah oh there he is
there's equilibrium so what is a bit
confusing sometimes is you see you've
got your
your squad mates and they will follow
you in formation even if you're going
entirely the wrong way
yeah so you need to
these guys must know where they're going
no you need to make sure you're
following the um the equilibrium
oh we've got missiles as well see these
are way better yeah absolutely
i don't think yeah i think the thai
fighters have a superiority complex
because i don't think that they're great
to be honest with you problem is we
don't need missiles yet so we need to uh
get some how do you do that because i
missed that i don't know last time i
just flew this way and then i had
missiles let's see what happens
okay everyone needs a full supply of
missiles
damn right we do okay i keep turning my
head
oh well yeah see i just got them how did
that happen
i think something threw them at us
missiles
exactly okay okay
so that's where we just were right yeah
as the empire
so yeah i'm assuming you're gonna have
to jump there too yeah
so i guess this way i think you know
what i think star star wars
was my first iteration of really seeing
a lot of voice acting for like
different characters and non-human
characters as well yeah that's true
actually
i think that was so so cool yeah it has
always been such a
wide range yeah oh
okay do i have to stop in this thing or
okay that's it
all right and then for the warp speed
and we jump
it would be cool if you had to dive your
energy to your
engines yeah like hyperdrive or
something yeah hyperdrive activate it
well you can see our throttle is uh oh
well it was jumping out
really hard yeah right so now we're i
guess we're playing this
same interaction or late slightly later
on
on the uh
oh yeah okay so i think he wants us to
fly underneath underneath the big enemy
ship
and close to the hull so the lasers
can't get us
thrusters okay boosting boosting
very very close i'm you're very close
yeah the lasers can't get me
if i'm close oh we lost one
echo five echo five is done it's just a
comrade i'm tying in battle we lost one
i know that otherwise like focus right
yeah right as if you weren't sure
okay okay i'll do a little bit of this
and now i'm going to pass you
down like i feel like i'm hogging this
uh no no no no ready
i'm not even shooting anything i'm just
enjoying this belt scratchy's hands
okay where are you enemies that's echo
leader
look bottom of your radar oh they're all
behind me that was
going the wrong way creeping up on you
oh no
i lied that's that's oh that's the enemy
giant
yeah that's the thing is back oh
fighters sorry
i'm getting getting lost i'm here for
now focus on
ties what is that
focus on oh sorry yeah the little ones
okay
there we go there's one you found one
time for some missile action i think
see so i need to lock on
and you knocked on lock on game
nah arrange god i think i flew the wrong
way for quite a while let's try one of
these ones
here we go there we go engage miss
alloway
yes
they're kind of sitting still they're
using my tactic from earlier
okay so half speeds okay that should be
good
oh yeah then you can actually keep up
with them yeah kind of whoa
almost a little wild okay
all right you hi stop shooting me
did you get oh you missed him yeah i did
oh i'll get this guy
get this guy
missiles missiles are definitely the uh
the easier way yeah definitely
oh i didn't kill that um
defend the convoy before it's too late
i'm gonna rebalance
rebalance my power i think
but yeah
all right fine time for some lasers
security come back
ah fine fine i'll be lazy
oh really trying to leave my target oh
okay
i was shooting at the other one but sure
i'll take that
you're getting quite good at this uh i
wouldn't go that far okay
oh no he was right in front of me i love
that
we're getting quite good at this little
little one sat in front of me just
chilling out
oh i think i might i might have missiles
oh no i've not got one one left
okay who wants it who wants it you you
sir
and come on lock on go
hey you did your job come on
oh that's what i was going to miss and
the other one as well
oh bro come on
how's my shields looking oh i've got it
um if you're watching this stream don't
expect this level of professionalism
that's flying from me because it's not
gonna happen
i'll i'll just put because i'm a coward
all my power and my shields because uh
i think this is the point where i get
shot a lot where is he oh oh
oh come on
[Music]
there we go nice cool okay
all right do you want to uh finish these
guys off and do the next bit sure
don't forget to uninvert okay
on invert
okay all right tell me how it's done
let's look at the radar where are we
so i think there's two small ones left
two actions left
oh oh they'll send more ties oh you've
got them all
oh okay here we go
so now we're with james again okay
okay the plot thickens and where are we
going
i think you're doing that thing again
when you're you're doing what i was
doing you're following
you're following the guys that's what
i'm doing you're following the guys who
are following you no that's right that's
that's james
that's jase sorry james i'm on your side
you are meant to follow him though
he was just uh he's up to the left to
the left
and up there he is okay follow that guy
all right oh enemies anybody's coming in
all right james come on save james from
the firefighters
oh lord jesus
there's so much going on i know i'm
trying to find the others
let me come out of this i think i'm in
the old note
please stop jumping where are you
running away i'm trying not to oh there
huh there get him
come on i'm afraid i used all your
missiles i'm sorry
you've left me you're right
oh my god come on actually another
another one of the things about the this
tv the 300t that is
really really good for gaming like this
is it's got so obviously we're all used
to playing on tv with game mode but this
has something called game enhancer plus
which is basically a whole bunch of
functionality
that when you put it in game mode all
these things turn on and
um you know make sure that the tv is set
up for gaming
which is like i think that's really
really nice refreshing because there's a
number of times i've spent
my time i spent in tvs you know when
you're going through the menus you're
like do i have a brightness right
have my are my like sharpness levels
right is the input lag gonna be there
have i set that stuff right
really easy on this on this one you just
set it to game mode and in fact it will
often auto detect the xbox as well
so and what that does is as well as
turning on you know the low input lag
and stuff like that
it also um enables variable refresh rate
and something called freesync
so if like say the xbox right now it
doesn't look like it is but if it was
like struggling with frame rate a bit
because of all the explosions
nice nice timing yeah and my other
spaceships on screen
let's say the frame rate's starting to
drop off it's aiming for 60 or whatever
and it's maybe hitting 40.
the refresh rate of the tv is going to
match that so you're not going to see
screen tearing or any other weird
artifacts that's really nice thing to
have
just kind of on a stand you'd have to
think about it it's just there
which is cool um and uh you know we
talked earlier how it can
it can show 120 frames so as soon as you
put it in game mode
it's ready for 120 hertz so if you've
got something that can
give 120 frames per second the tv is
going to match it i really like that
yeah yeah
there's a few other things as well
there's um there's a kind of something
called the dynamic black
equalizer which yet again just sets up
the contrast
for gaming to help you you know see
things in the shadows
and give a nice high contrast look um
and also you know it's got hdmi 2.1
ports as well so
it's ready for 8k as well that's super
important all this stuff one button
it's on and you have
one more to kill i think oh no you got
to kill the
quasar nice
are you going to ram it go on rabbits no
no oh you've got six missiles again
i want to miss out why am i okay you
want my one line
actually oh i think it did blow up it
blew up you got it
okay but i was i was like going
backwards without moving backwards
myself that was odd
i think it might have just been relative
to the shipments
okay
it's gonna be interesting i think it's
okay
echo three hurry howard is now at your
location
echo squadron keep the convoy safe while
the flagship engages the vigilance
okay let's come back where's the poncho
i think so yep ramming speed
yeah that is the radar get it go on
yes flash shields
you got missiles yep oh yes
that was close that was really good
their shields are weakening keep the
radar focused on us
not the convoy so how about this mission
we uh give the multiplayer game
yeah let's do it let's see how uh at
least i think it's got local multiplayer
it might but we'll see we'll see if
there's a thing now what do you think
about that with games like
the local multiplayer being less focused
on
you know couch co-op or sitting next to
someone like
yeah playing games you know against each
other whichever yeah look
big fan of whoa yeah big part of your
ramming speed um and yeah
big fan of looking forward very clearly
raider's tough but no match for much for
me
that's not the raider wow that's a
friend i think
right it's helpful that they all agreed
to um
the rebellion agreed that they were
going to fire red lasers yeah the empire
agreed they're gonna fight green ones
really helps you figure out who's on
your team
nearly done nearly done
49 i think it's got 48 health strength
or 47.
one second it's right next
oh uh you're getting you're getting shot
a lot
yeah my shields are gonna take a lot of
damage
it's all right you're fine 21 21 shields
that's plenty
right who needs them you can you can up
yeah please please no
don't shoot me oh it's like 21 holes
going i don't know
he's right there get him i'm moving
yes come on so close 17 16
15. hold up we need to heal up okay we
got it we got it
no way she was talking to i think she
was talking to the others actually oh
it's on two it's so nearly dead
two health come on i love this you're
like i'll let someone else get them yes
i'm going to uh barbecuing my ship
come on one is so close so close to
strength
about it come on you got it almost
missile for finish missile for the
finish got it
yes nice nice good job
i was being barbecued obviously uh
you're still alive
good work
see you do have the repair functionality
on this ship yeah yeah
okay so you've got shields and repair
yeah
but it's it's kind of strange you said
this earlier that the um the rebellion
seemed to have better
better kit than the empty right shoot me
the other way around but okay
trying to find glaives who's graves
oh you combined captain and james yeah
yeah i like it apologies
captain james is too much slaves i like
it for now when he's players
the star destroyer will be watching all
possible vectors they can still find you
okay it's risky but if we can destroy
the targeting system on the vigilance we
might throw them off the convoys trail
okay okay this is me they're really
fighting over a convoy that's what kills
me i mean i get it
but the empire i didn't think would be
fighting over this i thought they would
have left yeah who's going to be in this
in this refugee combat there must be
someone important
right exactly it's a lot of a lot of
stress over
one convoy
so you gotta you're trying to take that
take out their targeting system right
now oh what's happening
there we go
this feels very in star wars i know oh
oh
oh oh no oh no
the engine i'm farewell cool wow this is
gonna
no you're you're still going you've
still got a whole five whole five health
left
as low it's arguably too much there you
go
40 40 45. no jay please
a little scream that's okay so what are
you meant to be blasting
these yeah is that the target
we're getting in there keep firing okay
nice yep close it's close but you're
hanging in there
for good luck
okay here we go again yeah
i don't know yes
good stuff all right
oh it's nice let's go let's get off
range
all right get out of there around the
corner whatever happens next
uh up up to the right
good oh did you oh you were so close
okay we gotta get we gotta get there
that was so close i was so close
hopefully that was the checkpoint like
oh no oh no it's fine yeah
present for light speed yeah that was
right it oh okay all we need to do is
get here
oh i'm i'm i feel bad now i'm getting
the glory i've done all the hardest work
and i'm just gonna be like
oh you need to fly straight sure i can
fly straight it won't let me boost
though
you have to put the air fire earlier the
energy for the engines
to boost oh yeah so you do
cowboy's ready
prepare for light speed nice that was
fun
yeah that was really good that was good
cool well
there's a couple of things we can try
actually um one
another feature of the tv on the samsung
q800t is that it's got multi-view so
let's say we were just playing uh
there and thought our skills could do
some improvement what we could do is
actually while we're playing
pull up say like a youtube video or
something
yeah yeah we're someone who is actually
good at the game and we can watch them
play
and then hopefully get better um
so see if that's something um
we can maybe try that in a wee bit once
once we've maybe dabbled in some
multiplayer so do some multiplayer and
then some multi-view
so uh prologue completed nice let's go
back to the main menu
that's really good i didn't even think
about that that's an awesome feature
yeah yeah well we'll give that a go in a
minute
but let's see if we can do local
multiplayer can we do
dogfight okay uh start matchmaking
oh this looks like it's gonna be online
oh it sounds that sounds dangerous that
sounds scary
okay um but we can do
usually star wars games do have like a
local well like when i think of like the
battlefront games
yeah i'm not sure this one does but um
does have a quick message which again i
think is just um
gonna be multiplayer but we can we can
take our skills online
see how it goes um i'll let you do it
first because i feel like
you're more skilled you've got the
training you don't like to crash
yeah i feel like i have a weird
propensity to just well i don't know
i think compared against people who have
spent many hours playing this game
uh we may we may struggle
i'm gonna see i think i might need to
try and find
how we uh mute anyone else online
yeah uh mute voice and text
can i do that to everybody nice
all of their the opposing team are
automatically muted mute you
mute you oh i on ucg
cool okay good stuff we're ready ready
there
ready to jump in oh it's actually going
to be a 5v5 that's fun
oh no i'm really going to let this slide
down it's all right i think
i don't know what it is like whenever i
jump in a vehicle
in a game i just have a propensity to
crash it like i just want youtube to do
this because i feel like i'm just going
to crash everywhere
crashing cars crashing tie fighting
so uh what what games do you play uh
online multiplayer
a variety i really love right now i'm
playing a game called spell break
oh yeah yeah super cool super fun like a
magical
um battle royale yeah i've not played it
yet but i've seen i feel like i've seen
it everywhere this is
so good it um it's definitely fun and if
you're like someone who likes like
avatar lost airbender
or harry potter or something like that
you're definitely going to be aligned
with that okay so that's fun online
uh i don't think i've played anything oh
phasmaphobia
oh yeah yeah playing some plasmaphobia
with friends that's
super cool and funny oh cool shut in the
door when i leave my friends in the
house it's great
oh i was going to try to mulch to my
friends but it wouldn't let me
well actually i need to go i need to put
inversion on that's what i need to do
yeah i thought you you mentioned the day
you were playing with apex you know
played that on yeah a little bit of apex
as well
um new season trying to get used to it
um i'm not using the new map and i'm
also not that good of a player
so it makes me a little bit slower and
more rubbish than the others but still
playing that a little bit fortnight from
time to time when we just want to have
fun
play you know some more of a goofy
battle royale so you can have more fun
with it
apex is very serious yeah it can be a
bit
yeah it gives me i'm hoping that
this game is going to be quite uh
forgiving to new to new players as well
we'll find out
um yeah i really i'm not sure i've
really got the hang of yeah of the
combat in terms of like
how to how to guide how to follow people
effectively yeah so we're gonna
i feel like i lose sight of them very
quickly and easily okay here we go let's
hide the name plates look at this map
oh this is gonna be here we go i should
have the advantage right
we've got the tv that's showing me all
the enemies in the shadows i
should be able to win this this is
awesome oh no i'm a tie fighter though
okay oh god oh i haven't inverted you
have i
okay sorry guys just let me just let me
nobody
oh i'm going
okay cool we're good now i just launched
something
this map is gorgeous i really like it
oh it's happening am i missing the
action i think i'm missing all the
action i think you're turning on your
side
and yeah there you go whoa oh i'm being
shot i'm being shot
oh you don't have shields oh this is oh
wow
wow yeah um yeah that was it was
really well that was that was exactly
how i wanted it to go
look at all my evasive bags oh come on
they were there's three of them [ __ ]
me
okay okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
maybe that should be the end of our uh
foray into oh no okay i've got another
let's see this level out and then maybe
oh is there like a repair like a repair
beacon there okay right
oh that's cool okay here we go come on
cam must get
one kill okay you don't have to win but
get one
now one of the things as well that that
should be helping me is uh
in this studio right now we got a lot of
bright lights and everything but one of
one of the things i really like about
this tv
is that it's got anti-reflection coating
on it
so it's like it's like layers of this
really really tiny filters
which um basically diffuse any light
that hits it so what it means
is while you're being destroyed by the
enemy
at least you're not seeing your own face
in the dark areas on the tv
you know at least i don't have to see
myself as i get
absolutely destroyed at this game i
really like that feature i think that's
cool
because i don't know
okay i think come on here we go
this this was maybe oh come on that's
something
yeah i really should be rolling more i
think i need to be doing more
more oh wait that's not me that's right
you'll be back in five five seconds
um okay the other good thing about the
uh it's much easier to talk now i'm not
flying
the good thing about the anti-reflection
technology is uh it improves the viewing
angle as well
so you could like if you all gathered
around the character playing this
together you can sit right in the edge
and still get a nice view on the tv
which is really helpful
all right do better than me okay well to
do that all you need to do
is land one hit on an enemy oh yeah and
it's inverted
what's literally like how am i
controlling it okay
okay you're still alive nice the key was
to pretend you're a piece of space
debris
and uh let me show you all right come on
there's one oh yes targeting the enemies
that's a good plan
oh what are you doing i don't i don't i
don't know
up to the right to the right yes go on
go on land a hit
come on jay i can't hear you leaving i
believe in you i believe in you
uh
nice nice nice rolling keep dodging
okay very well equipped i think maybe we
should go back to
this thing yeah i think we're race
quitting we are full on rage quitting
yeah absolutely
oh gosh uh yeah so long so long friends
good speed um so i think it's going to
be uh
seb and sam in the in the control area
are going to help us with multi-view so
okay when you guys are ready we really
need those tips
because we are struggling um so should
we jump back into the story
and play a bit more of that i think
that's a good idea
uh i was i was enjoying the it was much
more much calmer
yeah less stressful hit some enemies i
feel like we were just fodder
just waiting to be
okay there is actually there is a
training mode in there which we probably
should have done
in the um in the kind of free play
multiplayer section of the game
so okay i think that would probably
teach you how to be better
no you don't want that okay i think what
we'll do is let's see if we can
try the multi-view hopefully it'll work
through the wall
so let's say we wanted to get better at
this game
you pull out your phone okay um oh okay
no i don't think we're quite ready sorry
i missed
i misread that message okay so what's
happening here
is it oh are we we're our same character
no you character
that's that's not us that's grace what's
our character's name again
psy okay
oh it's i'm not it's james
so i'll just say i'm honored
to assume command of the temperance in
this fleet yeah so come on
he
[Music]
i wouldn't
[Music]
i care i like to know who i'm working
for
right i'm on team frisk here yeah like
he knows what he's doing
galaxy who don't have a death knock on
you
ah grace the day ain't over yet
come on back to the temperance
i always like in star wars you can you
can see the animal that is inspired
yeah races so he was a fish guy yeah and
then
the other one was a lizard guy yeah
oh cool there you are hello
i'm zarel this looks awesome and this
here's the temperance
pride and joy i imagine you're excited
to join the action
so i think you might be able to
customize your uh your spaceships here a
bit
i got your new pilot over here you go
ahead i'll meet you
all right while uh well gunny
says hello to us let's see if we can try
this multi-view functionality okay let's
talk after the briefing yeah
all right something's happening here
yeah okay
so we're connecting to uh seb's iphone i
believe
and hopefully it's gonna bring up on the
screen
it might be struggling through the wall
no oh it's bringing up a video
oh no it's replaced the whole view
rather than multi-view right now but it
is
we did do this earlier calling me
impressive anyway at least at least this
way
we're getting some tips because we're
watching uh like uh
um what's wrong i'm looking for like a
kill streak
yeah a kill streak so oh
okay we're back and back back to the
game now i think it might be because
we're trying to do this through the wall
probably let me just get rid of those
menus
all right what was gunny saying enter
briefing room
like how over there oh you can't
actually walk okay oh you have to select
oh you push a
right right right i get it i get it
here he is excellent otto meet our new
vanguard five
hello the one who saved your skin at
foster haven
did i i don't know do you remember when
you rhymed
and you rammed into the enemy's shift my
own skin
a real honor very safe
but a good pilot shouldn't just he's
definitely going to send you on some
sort of suicide mission
you know that's going on here right he's
talking you up
there's no shortage of that around here
right
let's get you briefed welcome back to
the front line van gogh
he's too nice to be from the empire yeah
i know absolutely the way they like lady
was speaking
you know she's very harsh okay
do you trust him though that's my
question i do you do you don't think
he's a double agent
no i think he's gonna turn around and i
trust lyndon james
you don't think it's gonna be a trap
okay bring our new pilot to the rental
system's borders
the scouts we sent to investigate
haven't reported in
find out what happened to them oh great
so you're literally sending us into a
trap so
there you go thanks james that's where
you're headed
if i was still an imperial well i'd send
jamming ships there
knowing the empire i expect they're
using these jamming vessels to disrupt
our long-range calms
they'll have thai squadrons in tow
destroy all imperial squadrons and
jammers
all right there you go i'll be ready to
destroy low stuff uh
i mean including my ship yes
i wonder actually we may get options of
different uh different ships at this
point well in the video we just saw the
the person was flying a different type
of um
empire ship ah really i believe so speak
with nope nope okay
kyo oh hey
i'm keo welcome to vanguard squadron
okay here we go
yep we've got the uh multi-view going oh
this is awesome
yeah i went from semi-pro racing uh
we'll see this in a second
but everyone in vanguard so you can i
think the example we said earlier was
the right way to go
there you go you're playing the game but
you can also be watching
i mean we've got a youtube video here on
gamespot but it could be anything
you know whatever apps you have on your
phone basically you can ask me people
at the same time so it depends on the
game you know if you're what if you're
playing fifa
maybe you'd want to have an actual
football game on and you're kind of
doing at the same time or
in this case a video to make us much
better at the game
wow so let's see yeah you're right that
is a different ship yeah it is
look at that what tips can we take okay
so the aiming is seems to be important
this person's actually aiming aiming
aiming is important
right right okay that's cool and the
other thing about this as well is you
can
we've got these windows equal sizes you
can customize it however you like so you
could have like almost like a tiny
little picture picture in the corner
yeah or you could have like it mainly
you know your second screen
however you want to do it really
unfortunately it's so good
so like i just remember back in the day
when i was like trying to find out
maybe a walk through for maybe breath of
the wild or anything like that
yeah no need to pause and the great
thing is because the tv is so big
you're not really worried about losing
you know that real estate you can just
be like it's cool i got space for both
that's good yeah it's awesome all right
i think uh i think we've got all the
tips we need
just stare and don't die yeah i think
yeah i think
i also think if we were to um play
officers is also
the sensitivity i think that's affecting
our steering as well
all right so exit okay uh exit briefing
rim
the door back to the hangar okay
now can you can you customize if you
look at your ship there what can you do
oh no
that's serelda frisk
what's he got to say
nice to meet you squad calls me frisk
only grace calls me by my real name and
only when she's mad
okay no it's not often you find a
handsome fella like me
fighting for the rebellion uh new
republic
okay whatever we are now
it's funny because
the multi-view system we just showed
there obviously we showed it on
the tv we were playing on q800t but i
haven't even mentioned the tvs that we
got behind us
all the way through the stream these are
the uh the q90t
which is 55 inch and it goes up to 4k
um and the great the great thing about
this is it can do the multi-view as well
and it's still a huge screen so
that's really useful and pretty much all
the other functionality we've talked
about so far today
it's the same for these tvs really the
only main difference is that
this guy does the 8k it goes up to 8k
right okay that's really impressive
is this gunny there's also slight
differences on the
hdr tech as well i think but yeah
like i said okay stay sharp keep your
nose clean and we'll be off to a good
start
okay okay keeping your nose clean
apparently is very important in the
spacepod okay
sorry sorry shut up gummy shut up buddy
all right okay
let's do it let's do it let's prepare
for lunch
okay what are you gonna and our new
change
a good all-rounder that'll stand up to
any starfighter or capital ship in the
imperial fleet that's hard
can you so can you change things i don't
i don't think you can
you have options yet okay we're going to
unlock them okay fair enough
all right you go you sure yeah sure okay
you saw me in the multiplayer yeah
you saw me yeah fair enough oh we do
have feet
oh feet confirmed and extra controls
that's cool it reminds me of those um
stimulators and you know when you used
to go to like a arcade or
a theme park when you're a kid and you
get into the simulator and it goes like
this
which reminds me of this i think i only
ever went one of those once
really always wanted to and uh and then
i remember being really disappointed
because the game in it was rubbish yes
it always would be the ones the ones
that look
slightly moved it's gonna be amazing
this is not as cool as i thought it was
going to happen
okay okay here we go
i'm a big fan of all this like i know it
i know it's like built
it's not like action stations right now
but when you've got this kind of
contextual build up
yes i really like these moments and it's
like oh this is what this thing does i
love
this bit because it makes it feel more
real mm-hmm
okay thank you
all right what do i need oh press press
a to launch
complicated press a and say to launch
okay launched
that's actually why do you remember but
the time i played elite dangerous is how
difficult it is
to just launch or to dock so easy to
just blow your ship up actually
yeah no i'm okay yeah oh i need to uh
guess what invert yeah you guessed it
okay okay
there that's kidding gummy's in a
different
ship is that right
uh oh yeah i can scan that so this is
keo okay up here and you are
gunny obviously and then the y wing we
have
oh yeah we met him earlier the handsome
guy yeah yeah yeah
i mean grace that's great okay cool
our jump points just ahead i think
you're following the wrong one i
definitely am yes it's so easy to do
like following the blind yep
okay uh should i be going faster or
something than a long day
um right but you could have you could be
straight and yeah there you go
okay power to engines
here we go hyperspace coordinates
calculated
engines are hot let's do this vanguard
squadron
all right and
we're gonna go oh yeah there we go
i could definitely play this in vr i
would love to try it
okay yes
so what we're doing again we're looking
for ships that disappeared
and also looking for jam enemy jamming
ships or something like that
yes
um enemy ship jammers things yeah jamie
dodges
and tea yeah good stuff
republic
[Applause]
we should investigate the signal and
regroup with them okay
which which way we going am i am i going
the right way this time oh yeah follow
grace good
okay always my worry
me too grace me too shields
engines lasers i think engines right
makes sense right now yeah yeah yeah
there's our target where who
where's that target who what oh that
i'll stop stop scouts didn't make it
oh
nope that's you you're not debris
i think i'm literally right next to it
yeah let me know we can't let our allies
die in vain
i'm trying i'm trying to scan the debris
oh my gosh
you guys are so close okay okay i'll get
this
i'll get this we would never survive in
space
it's the finesse moves oh my god i
thought i'd stopped sorry i thought it
stopped at my back i was just doing
loops around them there
oops okay here we go here we go to
everyone who i just made throughout
apologies follow me oh i thought i was
scanning this
are they related they got bored of
waiting for me to do i got tired of you
they're like i did it
no i didn't matter frisk
sound is good as well oh yeah that's
that's a good point actually we we've
i'm just going to turn it i can't put it
too low because it's going to come
through on the stream as well
but uh we are we have been listening to
this game
through the q 900t soundbar
which is uh right in front of the tv
there which you can see thanks to seb's
wonderful vision mixing there you go
and um yeah the really cool thing about
when you plug the sandbar into one of
these tvs
is normally when you plug it uh soundbar
into your tv it like swaps out the
what speakers you're using so the tv
speakers will turn off oh i'm being shot
and uh yeah but with the soundbar they
utilize these speakers on both
okay come on fire get it get it getting
it wait is that
i thought that was a friendly ship oh
dirty don't get it don't get it then
no that's it there don't pay attention
to me okay you're getting shot
yeah thank appreciate it appreciate the
tips there
i mean i'm just making sure you're aware
yeah no it was a very helpful advice
yeah okay
so i'm gonna power the shields it's
probably a good idea right now
oh come on
yeah yeah yeah i know me too we're all
taking fire
you see me bragging about it oh nice
shot nice shot
see i'm worried that i'm getting hit a
lot right now
oh
i'm running away my glass is broken
that's the last thing to happen in space
quite important in space
it keeps the air in those times i'm
trying okay ties now right okay as high
as i can do
bounce my my power
find the enemies there they are okay
there we go
there we go now we got it
nice come on yeah it's just for that
video we watched a lot of you
whoa nice straight through the fire is
that one more
no it's not that's just the cloudy dust
that's uh but i shot it
oh we're friends your friend
there he is there he is oh nice
so done frisk that was great
i think i think i knew frisk was a good
shooter
i don't trust my ability to scan things
well that's it there
oh no okay so the key was to not go too
close okay
but it's quite break oh
again let's see
balance set my power
and straight straight oh wait remember
timber oh that's why
straight through the remains of the
spaceship
oh that was scary okay here we go
lead the wave who's vanguard five is
that is that us that's me are we
vanguard [ __ ] we all go
we are van gaal we're getting vanguard
we are vanguard five yep
nice okay so another another leap
whatever comes next we face it together
okay
imperial okay ahead okay
that's the source blackout
is this jupiter uh it looks inspired by
jupiter
okay oh what's this mobile evasion you
can invade a missile by making several
sharp turns uh-oh
you ready for this jen i think you are i
think you are i believe in you i believe
in you
so uh if we want to just have a look
a closer look because i realized we just
looked at it through the the over the
shoulder camera but
we've got some closer shots of the q
900t which is the soundbar i mentioned
earlier
what i was trying to say while i was in
the middle it's much easier to explain
things while you're playing the game
uh while i was mid-dog fight what i was
trying to say is that when you connect
this sandbar to your uh your tv um
you actually get the sound from both
both the speakers within and around the
tv
and the q900t soundbar itself
so it's nice that you're you know you're
not wasting those speakers
and you are not wasting any time
destroying these enemies missiles
missiles there we go nice
oh that was uh i thought i was going to
i will never tire of your attack this is
great
just in case ram at the end why not
why not
i genuinely thought i was going to miss
that
where'd it go there it is
no wonder you have a keys crack in your
glass now
i don't mean to do it that's the thing i
genuinely don't
i'm just so poor at controlling this
okay
it's the speed it's so cool oh that was
nice
see and you swerved away afterwards as
well that was great trying to get start
points out there you go
yes okay oh there's still a little tie
fighter
yeah that's fine i'm just gonna get them
oh it's it's when you get that thing
where you you just like fly past each
other
and then it's like if if they just turn
then you then you're going to miss it
oh yeah that's good you're you're doing
well you're at the half speed you know
your throttle's just right
so you've got maximum turning efficiency
come on
get him switch powers here
i've lost him so you've gone full laser
power
yeah i've lost them
where am i where's my map my radar
it should be here there we go
there we go come on
that's one
so close not many left it's another
championship
yeah that is i've got the name
i've got no missiles oh this is good i
know you've got four you've got four i
just got four it didn't launch for me
i think did it have the green the green
square oh that's why yeah he's got it
there he's locking on [ __ ]
looking on you gotta hold steady there
you go oh
there you go don't miss out nice
[Music]
oh close though yeah my shields are
definitely taking a hit right
uh now dan i don't mean to alarm you but
uh i know
you're uh i'm no expert but i think your
ship's on fire yeah can you repair it
do you have anything you're all out of
l1 oh wait no try again there i think
you've got one yeah
yeah there we go so it just kind of
reboots over time okay
a little little droid just zooming
around your ship right now fixing it
come on get it lasers oh that's gone
there we go okay so you've just got
tight fires left there's one
not terrible high praise indeed
uh it disappeared i think then
uh okay up to your to your left just
twist it lock on you got it
yep there there you go you want to team
up
oh yes very nice
yes uh just get this ship to stop cueing
me it's all right so you're back up to
uh yeah
80 80 yards yeah you go you're not bad
not bad i think you're definitely
getting a bit better
yeah it's technically again you need to
practice i don't think we're quite ready
for
the world of online multiplayer no no no
it's
a harsh lesson
head towards cabazz
okay oh yeah you got the hang of this
i'm just trying to use the engines give
it a little boost yeah i'm getting used
to that bit it's the shooting and the
aiming
yeah yeah piloting no no problem yeah
the combat bit maybe you should uh leave
the rebellion and be like a freighter
captain or something you know driving
from a to b i would be supportive from
that side
yeah you know exactly i love the pink
and
um fire yeah the thrusters jets yeah the
visuals in this game are really great
there's so much going on at once and we
can really appreciate it
let's finish off that
turn come on there you go oh
almost
watch out it's your friend
they don't mind things they do if you
shoot them they'll be complaining
like i'm on your side i just literally
am doing nothing right now
you're dodging you're uh you're bait
distracting the enemy
allowing your friends to come off it's
tactics there we go here you go
i'm not saying thank you
it's the they just move so quickly yeah
it's hard actually i think locking on
definitely yeah remembering to press a
that's why i always keep forgetting
yeah because you have to cycle through
and i'm shooting at the space right now
your lord gave me
tired
strength
balancing the powers just yeah here it
is
nice
oh evasive action glad you're here have
you had to dodge the missiles yet i've
done it yeah i don't know
you did do that okay because i remember
it gave me that warning but i couldn't
remember if you actually
had to do it yeah i did okay i didn't
know if i
seated though i think one more one more
tie fighter and then i think we may have
to
leave it there okay one more come on
make it a good one i think they're gone
oh
okay well you already did it really i'm
a genius well then
well thank you everyone for watching
this stream um if
you just kind of tuned in halfway what
we were doing is we were trying to put
the samsung q800t through its paces with
the xbox series x playing of course star
wars squadrons
did you enjoy it i did i really did i
need to practice
i just think it just looks beautiful on
the tv it's like you're in the
in the ship itself i just need practice
that's all okay a couple more
yeah absolutely i mean same for me
definitely but yeah i think this was the
size of the tv really really won it for
me today like in this we're in quite a
big studio
that doesn't feel like it because it's
just filling your field of view which is
really cool
um and we also we mentioned some of the
other features which which we've been
showing off today so
the whole game enhancer plus system
which was like the low input lag
um the variable frame rate we didn't see
any screen tearing anything like that
if the xbox at any point was suffering
we have no ideas
it was all really smooth and of course
the tv can do that 120 frames per second
we didn't see it in the studio today
because of the streaming setup but we do
know
if you have this at home with your xbox
and you plug it in you can get your 4k
and your 120 and in fact this game i
think only runs 4k 120
on the xbox um and then when you combine
it with this tv
you can have all the frames and all the
resolution which is lovely
so thank you very much for watching
everybody this was the second of three
streams where jay and i are going to sit
down
and play games on the samsung 800 t q
sorry q 800 t and next time our last
episode what are we playing
fifa fever 21 your favorite game oh god
yay
exactly so i want to know if that's
going to help me be better at fifa where
i can actually
see the ball without having to do this
which is usually yeah
and um if you want to find out more
about any of the products we've talked
about today just check out the link in
the description
thanks very much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you